Hello, hello, everybody.
Hello.
Alright, guys.
Okay, so I may sound very low energy today because if you guys don't follow me on Twitter, I had to take Dad, Doki Amber Doge, to the vet today at 9 in the morning.
So I'm very tired.
I have... don't worry, I have day-old coffee.
This is my life right now.
I have day-old coffee.
to get me by because I couldn't finish my coffee yesterday while I was working.
So here's a little... for those who don't follow me on Twitter, sorry, I'm going to start the stream a little bit down, a little bit low energy.
But I know some people would like to have an update on what's going on with Doki Amber Doge, with Dad.
He's not here right now.
He's actually at the dog sitter.
So basically what happened is that a couple of days ago, I noticed that he hasn't...
He hasn't been using my bed to sleep on.
And I got, you know, and you know, it's almost close to summer.
And it is getting hot right now.
So I thought that maybe it's because it was a little too hot.
And he didn't want to be under the covers or anything.
He didn't want to use the bed.
So that's why he's using his own dog bed.
So I didn't think much too much about it.
So just because like, oh, it might be summer.
And he's just feeling a little too hot.
And the thing is, so this is basically like, every wiener dog's owner.
But Dad hurt his back.
So he's feeling pain in his back right now.
And I didn't initially thought that was a problem.
Because he was walking.
And like, he... The way he was moving seemed like he didn't care what's going on.
Like, so I didn't notice that he had back issues.
Because he was like, you know, he was peeing.
He was pooping.
He was moving.
He was walking.
He was doing little, like, scurries and stuff during walks and everything.
So I didn't realize, um, something was wrong.
And then I think like, a day or two later, um, I was like, you know, I was eating food at my desk because I was working.
And then, you know, he would usually come along because he's like, super food hungry.
And, uh, and so, but then he didn't like... So for those who own wiener dogs, uh, they, they would like, uh, like to like, uh, you know, get up on their hind legs and then put their, put their front paws on your legs.
And be like, get closer to you.
And so with that... So he didn't do that.
So I, that's when I knew that something might be wrong.
Um, because I was like, oh, why isn't he doing that?
Like, like he tried to, but then he like stopped himself.
So I, like, I was like, oh, that's weird.
That's very, that's very weird.
So, um, um, but then I was just like, oh, maybe he's just tired, you know?
Cause he was still acting normally.
Um, he was still acting normally in terms of like walking wise.
So I didn't think it was back issues just cause like he was walking normally.
He was eating.
He was, he was eating.
He was like, you know, demanding food and everything.
Um, I did notice that he wouldn't walk up to my room to demand stuff anymore.
He would bark from his bed.
So like, I should have seen that as like, oh, some, he doesn't want to get up.
So he, you know, like, you know, when like people are bedridden, they would just like stay in their bed and be like, get, but be like, I demand, I demand food or like nurse, help me.
Like stuff like that.
But he was just in his bed, just barking and whining at me and was just like, get over here and feed me like on his bed.
And then I would, you know, get up from my bed and then I like feed him and stuff like that.
And then he would get out of his bed and then start eating that.
He was like, you know, like, like Squidward.
He was like using the call buttons, like Spongebob, I require, I require you to change clothes for me and stuff like that.
Like, like he would do that.
Um, and, and then like after I do the things he wanted me to do, then he'll get out of the bed.
Um, but then so like, um, so I noticed he didn't like want to like, you know, lean on my leg for like, you know, if I'm eating something and he's like, I want human food.
He wouldn't do that.
But I still at that point, I still have yet to like piece together that it was back issues.
I just thought he was really tired.
Um, and he was just like feeling tired or something.
So, um, two days ago on Sunday was when I finally figured out it was back issues because when I was doing his walks, um, we encountered another dog and then it was a big dog.
So I like tried to pick him up.
I was like, okay, I would bend down and then he would like just go into my arms and then I pick him up.
But then when I did that, he tried to go to my arms.
Um, he would like, he would usually automatically go to my arms.
The moment I bent, like bend down and like, like give him like, you know, the pose being like, okay.
Like, you know, the carry pose, like get in my arms, like get my arms out.
And then he tried to get my arms and he started yelping.
I was like, oh, okay.
Okay, something is wrong.
Like, that's what I instantly knew.
Like, oh my gosh.
Okay, something is definitely wrong.
Um, and so I was like, okay, like he couldn't get on my arms because he yelped.
And I was just like, oh, he doesn't like being carried.
But then I already picked him up.
Now I like picked him up anyway, because I was like, okay, I don't want you near this dog, this giant ass dog.
Anyway, and then I touched his back and then he yelped again.
And I was like, oh, oh, no.
Okay.
Yeah.
Now I know what's going on.
And so, so, um, so, uh, I, you know, I called my vet and I go to vet.
And obviously, like Monday was Easter Monday.
It was Easter.
Okay, it was like long.
Sorry, it's not Easter Monday.
So Sunday was Easter.
And then they had long weekend.
So Monday was like they were busy on Monday.
So I was like, so but they could get me in on Tuesday could get me in today.
So I had debated for the longest time.
I was just like, all right.
So I either, I either like go to an emergency or wait for the good event.
So if there was like anything wrong with dad, I would take him to the emergency event.
But luckily they could put me in, like if I had to wait more than like one day, I'll take him to the emergency event.
So I took him, but then they were like, we can fit you in for tomorrow at 9am.
And I was like, okay, that's great.
Um, and so, uh, so I went to the vet and you know, she was very, too.
When I was in the Uber ride to the vet, he was like shaking a lot.
And then if you guys didn't know if a dog like licks his lips a lot, then he's like in pain or like he's like really stressed out or like anxious.
So I noticed when he's like, you know, in my arms while I was in the Uber, he was like licking his lips a lot.
And then he was like shaking a lot and everything.
And I was like, okay, this is like not good because, um, you know, he usually isn't like that.
When he's like to the vet, he would be like really happy, excited.
And, but like, if he's like anything, I saw notice he was like licking his lips, licking his like mouth a lot.
And that's when, you know, like he's like stressed and like in pain and everything.
So he can't like sit... I noticed like the way he was sitting, like he couldn't sit his normally way of sitting.
So, and even then it was like putting pressure on his back, I believe.
So, but like, yeah, when he was in his own bed, he was not reacting like that.
He was like, you know, obviously he knows like what position to sleep on and like how to lie down comfortably and stuff like that.
So like back before I like actually took him to the vet and realized it was a back issue.
He acted normally, except for the fact that he didn't want to be in my bed.
And, um, he, he was like, he just didn't want to be picked.
Like the moment I realized he didn't want to be picked up was when I realized something was wrong.
Because normally he's like really like pay attention to me.
I want attention and everything.
So, um, I was at the vet for like three and a half hours.
Uh, because like, you know, there was the examination.
Um, and they gave me a choice of either going to like neurologists to like, you know, if he had to get surgery or something or anything.
Because if you guys didn't know, like, it's a very common problem with wiener dogs.
And that's why I was like, no, like that's like, no, it's like something to do.
It could be like something related to like his disc for his spine.
Because, um, but he can still walk.
He still feels feeling in his back legs, which is great.
I'm really happy about that.
Um, and, and like, it's really common amongst like smaller dogs.
And especially wiener dogs.
So I think what happened was that he, I do have doggy stairs for the bed.
But sometimes when he hears, like, when he hears like food, he would jump off his bed.
And I think like, he might have like, um, hurt his back doing one of the jumps.
And I, I did buy an extra pair of stairs now.
Um, just in case like, you know, when he does come home.
Um, um, I'm going to try and make sure he used, I'm going to have two stairs.
One at the front of the bed.
And one, because my other stairs was at the back of the bed.
Um, and he does, he likes to, you know, get there as fast as possible with, for the food, like human food.
Um, so I did get like, like I did, uh, uh, get like another, I bought another stair, staircase for him.
For the front of the bed.
And I'm going to make sure like, you know, he's going to learn how to, you know, not jump off the bed anymore.
Um, for the front bed, um, for the front side.
Um, but he is getting older.
I do agree.
But like, he's still young enough for... I hope that recovery will be okay.
So the vet says it's still early stages.
So, um, it's still like early stages.
So, well, it's not like staircase.
It's like those like slanted stairs, you know?
It's sort of like low-key, um...
He's like middle-aged.
I'll say he's like middle-aged.
But yeah, it's not like those, like, you know, like those actual staircases.
It's like those like slanted stairs where it's like half stairs, half ramp type deal for like smaller dogs.
And basically the vet says that it could still be early stages because I didn't take him to a neurologist.
Because they were like, well, like obviously he was like, he still walk and he still has feelings in the back of his leg and everything.
And they were saying like, if I take him to a neurologist, like at best they're just gonna tell you to do the same thing which is like pain medication.
Um, and just like rest and like no movement until, uh, until like, uh, until he's better.
So, uh, I'm just hoping that that's basically the case where it will be like, he just said like rest up for two weeks.
And then after two weeks, we're gonna go back to the vet and like do a checkup and stuff.
And, uh, and that's what like, I just hope that that's basically it.
Um, and that he'll recover and then at best, I'll just have to make sure he doesn't jump as much anymore.
Um, but it was very scary.
I, I, there was like a, he had to get blood tests taken to like make sure the medication doesn't like conflict with like whatever he has.
So like, um, so like when he was getting his blood tests done, you know, I had to wait for like 40 minutes for that.
And like, I, I left, like, I left dad.
I like Doki Amber Doge at the vet.
And then like, I went to the coffee shop nearby and I was like crying in the coffee shop.
I was like, oh my God.
Oh, I hope he'll be okay.
Cause like, also like, I've been having a really rough month.
Not gonna lie.
I've been like super fucking stressed out in general.
I've been like really stressed out.
And like, you know, it's been a very unlucky month so far.
So I was like, oh my God, I hope he's okay.
So I was like drinking my London fog, like crying in the coffee shop while like some fucking university students were doing like practicing for a fucking, uh, uh, presentation or some shit.
While I was just like in the corner being like, oh my God.
I just hear this fucking group of university students is practicing for the goddamn stupid fucking presentation.
I, uh, uh, uh, um, um, um, anyway, um, but, oh my gosh.
So I also like when I, you know, I actually had to call my dog sitter to pick, um, him up with me.
So he's at the dog sitter right now because I didn't want to stress him out too much with the, with two back to back car rides.
Uh, um, and, uh, yeah, I know it's finals week too.
So she must've been like, oh man, she must be freaking out about finals week.
Like, um,
anyway, um, so because like during the car ride to the vet, um, to the vet, uh, he was like obviously incredibly stressed out.
And, um, um, I was really worried.
I didn't want to like stress him out even more, um, with like two back to back car rides and the decision to, the decision to like put him in dog sitter.
So he's going to be a dog sitter for two weeks until I take him back to the vet is because, um, just this oncoming week, I am incredibly busy.
Like the timing was just incredibly terrible for me because I have like tech rehearsals.
I have a convention later this week.
I have several sponsors I have to do, which means I won't be like able to monitor him 24 seven to make sure he doesn't move and everything.
And so I have a lot of things I have to do and be like, um, I have to do and like make sure I'm actually like on my PC.
And so like, there was no way I could commit to like taking care of dad, uh, like, and making sure he doesn't like move around too much when I have like a lot of stuff I have to do on the PC itself.
And like, obviously, I don't want that worry to be there for me as well while I'm like doing like a sponsor and like, you know, performing at a convention and everything.
So like, you know, I have to check up on him and I can't really do that when I'm in the middle of a sponsor.
And, uh, so it's a lot of money.
I was also low-key freaking out about the amount of money I have to pay.
Um, because if anyone is ever a vet, a dog owner or pet owner, vet bills are incredibly expensive.
And, um, um, and also like the dog sitter is not like some random dog sitter.
I like fucking Craigslist.
Um, it's actually a really, really good dog sitter.
Like, they give me like treats and gifts and stuff during like the holidays and stuff like that.
If I have the dog sitter like look after dad, um, like during the holidays or like his birth, like during like any special time or whatever, they actually give me like a little like doggy care package.
Like, they're like, oh, here's a little doggy care package with some new toys and some treats and stuff like that.
Um, um, and everything.
And they have, like, every time, uh, Doki Amber Doge dad would, like, um, be there, like, visit the dog sitter, they have, like, they would buy, like, they would give him, like, a box of, like, new toys and everything.
And then he, like, picks out a toy during the visits and stuff.
And they also give him, like, you know, grooming, like, they also, like, give him baths and ear cleaning and stuff like that.
So, you know, I do spoil him a lot by giving him a, like, hiring a really good dog sitter.
For him.
Because I do want him to have, like, a really good time.
And have, like... And it's also, like, a family, too.
So, like, it's, like, you know... Like, a middle-aged couple.
With, like, you know, a kid.
And, like... And, uh... So, they are... You know, he gets, like, a more family experience living with them.
And, um... They also send me, like, updates and stuff whenever... Like, you know, they send me updates and stuff every day.
And, you know, I also trust the dad to take care of dad.
In terms of, like, medication-wise.
Apparently, he told, like, the dad... The husband was the one that helped pick up me... Like, not me, though.
But, like... Because I went and, um... Grief ate their, like... What was it called?
Stress ate at a Korean restaurant right after.
Uh... They picked my dog up at the vet.
Uh... I was just, like... In a Korean restaurant.
Just, like... Stress eating.
Uh... As they play it.
When I... When... When, um...
When, uh... The husband picked up my dog at the vet.
I was just, like... Just sitting by myself at the Korean restaurant.
I'd be, like... Oh, my God.
At least he'll be happy.
Uh...
Anyway.
Yeah.
So...
So, uh... So, basically, like, the husband... I also, like... I'm worried myself about, like...
Doing medication and stuff for my dog.
Because he also needs, like... Uh... Like, there's, like, a shot he has to do.
Basically, he's on three types of medication.
And they're all sort of, like, to mitigate... Like, help heal his back.
And to mitigate the pain and everything.
And one of them is, like, a shot.
And I was, like... I don't trust myself with needles or anything.
So, like... I'm glad that, like...
You know... You know, I was... You know, like, when your pet is, like...
Has to be medicated.
And then it's your dad.
Or, like...
Like, it's the dad who usually does the medication.
And stuff like that.
So, I live alone.
I don't have, like...
You know, I get scared doing all of that by myself.
So, that's why I also asked the dog sitter to help me take care of dad for me.
For the next two weeks.
Because I was, like...
Oh, my gosh.
This...
I'm so scared doing all of this.
And I don't trust myself to be able to, like, provide the best care possible for him.
So, that's why I...
You know, I was willing to pay.
It's gonna...
I know it's a lot.
Because when I was in Japan...
And he was...
He was there.
He was...
You know, when I was in Japan.
And, like...
He was at the dog sitter while I was in Japan.
It was a lot.
So, like...
I know, like...
The two-week visit is gonna...
Oh, my God.
I'm not thinking too much about it.
But, like...
I'm gonna try and work...
More...
Like...
Harder the next two weeks.
To, like...
You know...
Be able to...
Like...
Well, I can't afford his care.
You know...
But to, like...
Make back...
The amount that we...
Obviously spending.
And I really appreciate...
Thank you so much for the super chats, everybody.
I really, really appreciate it, guys.
Without your support.
And, like...
You know, guys being here and everything.
I'm able to provide, like...
Really good care for...
Doki Amber Doge.
And I really, really appreciate it, guys.
Because, like...
You know, I don't have to worry too much.
I don't have to worry about, like...
Money-wise.
Regarding, like...
The care for him.
And it really means a lot.
And everybody knows how expensive like taking care of pets are when like, you know, there's like a medical emergency.
And I'm hoping that we don't have to go through the surgery route because that's like something I'm like most worried about.
So I'm hoping that... They said it's early stages regarding like his back problem.
So usually if it's early stages, it's just like... And he can walk.
He like moves fine.
He was like shaking.
Like he's... Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So you know how when dogs are anxious, they like do like a little shake and stuff.
So he did that a lot.
But then I didn't realize he was like shaking because he was anxious and stuff.
So I didn't think it was anything wrong.
So he's been like moving around a lot and stuff like that.
So he still has movement and everything.
So that's great to know.
And I... Oh my gosh.
I just love wiener dogs so much.
But they come with so many problems.
But it's like... They're cute.
They're so cute.
And it's like... But they do come with a lot of problems.
If you are ever a dog owner.
And you are you know financially not as secure as you would like to be.
I highly recommend never getting a wiener dog.
Because they are the most expensive little fuckers.
I have to take care of.
Because they have so many issues.
They have... They... I was with the vet.
And then um... You know...
Um... The vet was like... Is...
The vet was like... Um... Is he allowed to have treats?
I was like... Oh yeah.
He's just allergic to chicken.
And then... The vet was like... Wow.
You're the perfect... You're the peak perfect wiener dog.
Allergies and back problems.
And I was just like...
So... For those who don't know...
So...
For those who don't know...
Wiener dogs... Also have...
Allergy issues too.
So they're most...
Most... Likely...
Allergic to everything.
So...
That's...
Winner... Winner...
Peak performance.
And...
Um... Yeah.
So...
So like wiener dogs...
When they get old...
Like...
They're not older.
But usually happens...
As like they turn one or two.
They also develop allergies and balding issues as well.
So he has like balding issues on his ears and stuff.
So he doesn't have like a lot of hair on his ears.
Because he is a winter dog and he hit the jackpot in terms of like, the genetic lottery.
And you'll notice in the photos where his ears are lighter than the rest of his body is because it is genetics where like winter dogs do go bald, but it only like, it only affects like the front part of his body, like the chest area and like his ears.
So like, it does happen.
Um, so, so I'm hoping that the two weeks will be okay for him.
And after that, like, I'm going to make sure he never fucking jumps again.
Uh, if I have to, if he does still jump when he's on my bed, I will revoke his bedtime, like his, like his bedtime on my bed.
So like, and then I'll just be like, you just stay in your fucking dog bed.
I don't care anymore.
Like, like, if he still fucking, you know, hears food time and still jumps off my bed, I will be revoking his privileges on being on the human bed now.
Um, but right now he just has been like, I think he knows because he has back issues that he has refused to get on the bed, on the, on my beds.
And he's just been on his dog bed and everything.
So, yeah, so I'm just, I'm just hoping everything will be okay, um, in the next two weeks.
And I really appreciate, guys, all the super chats, all the akkas, all the, every super chat you guys are giving.
Nefers, thank you again for the akkasupa.
Take my energy and money, dad.
Thank you again for it.
Thank you for the akkasupa.
Otaku, thank you for the akkasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Cyber, thank you for the magenta super.
Here's my get well soon dad text.
Thank you so much.
Hongeorge, thank you for the magenta super for dad bills.
Get well soon dad.
Thank you, thank you.
I really, really appreciate you guys.
I'll do the other Super Chats.
Thank you all the Super Chats for the others soon as well, but thank you guys.
I really, really do appreciate it.
I'm sorry I started off the stream like a little bit downer news, but also like a little optimistic.
Sorry, I can't English as well.
I have barely slept today.
Because like I said, I was awake since like 8am today.
I did take a little nap.
I did take a two-hour nap and I had to get up, obviously.
I had to like get up to like give like the dog sitter like his food and his favorite toy and stuff like that.
Because, you know, they picked him up at the vet and everything.
So he didn't get his food or he didn't get his like shampoo, his allergy shampoo, or like his favorite toy or like, you know, his like stuff to make sure he's comfortable and everything.
So I had to wake up.
I had to wake up like after my two-hour nap to just like give him everything, give the dog sitter everything.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the Magenta Soup.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Thank you guys.
Miller, thank you for the Magenta Soup.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dad Dawgs.
I really appreciate you guys.
My manager was like, you should cancel stream and just like relax and like, you know, just like have time to remind yourself.
But I honestly, I really wanted to stream today because streaming and just getting my mind off things and just being with you guys helps a lot for me too.
Cause I was like, no, I told my manager that like, I rather just stream and just like, you know, be in the company of you guys, like with my dragoons and everything.
Because it always does make me feel a lot better.
And it does cheer me up a lot.
And I just want, I didn't really want to be alone.
You know, cause I'm alone now, right now.
Cause obviously dad's not here.
He's at the dog sitter.
So, um, he's not here.
And I was like, uh, it doesn't make me feel better streaming for you guys.
And like you guys being here with me and you know, let's just hope for, um, his speedy recovery.
Um, because you know, um, it's crazy when like, he got his medication shot.
Uh, uh, when he got his medication shot at the vet, um, he was like moving around.
He's like, I'm better now, but obviously it was like painkillers.
So, so he's like, yippee!
And he was like moving around.
And he was like trying to like, you know, like, he was like trying to, you know, like put his front paws.
And standing up on his hind legs, put his front paws on people.
He's like, yippee!
I'm okay!
I was like, no!
Get down!
Like, um, me, the dog sitter, and like the vet were like pushing him down.
And I was like, no!
You're not better!
It's just the painkillers talking!
And he was like, you just don't feel anything!
We were like, every time he was doing it, we were like, no!
Stop!
You're not, it's just the painkillers!
You're not better!
He was just like, yeah!
I'm good now!
And he's like moving around and everything.
And when we got like his shots.
And so...
But yeah, like I'm just, like I said, I'm hoping for the two weeks that he'll recover.
And thank you guys so much, Shallon, for the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it.
And guys, I know like some of you guys who can't, or like, like cold deaths, who are like, I can't spend more, sadly, due to bills.
But this is for Dad.
Thank you again for Super Chat.
I really appreciate it, guys.
You really don't have to, but I really appreciate it.
Please look after yourself first, though.
But thank you guys.
Bite Size!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
We're all praying for Dad.
Speedy and full recovery!
Thank you guys!
Thank you again!
But yes, thank you, everybody, for being, you know, like, feeling for Dad, for like, wanting to make sure he's okay.
Because, you know, he's been part of my life and being part of your life as well, because of all the stories I share of him and like all the, like, you know, him being like such a huge part of my stream and everything.
And like, you know, he's as much as part of my life as yours.
So I really appreciate you guys showing so much care for him.
And like, you know, for donating and, you know, wishing him well and everything.
And just to make sure he's like okay and stuff like that.
So, like, the dog sitter will tell me, like, if anything comes up, if there is anything that does come up, they will message me.
Or they will message me and we'll take him to the vet ASAP.
If anything happens.
But I hope that, you know, it's just...
Because like, you know, he's for like four days.
He wasn't at the vet for four days when it first started.
So I hope that like, you know, from there, it's just mostly him recovering.
He just needs to recover.
He just needs to rest and relax.
And then eventually, like, you know, his back would feel a lot better.
And it's mostly just, you know, he can't...
He just can't jump anymore afterwards.
I need to make sure he doesn't jump anymore.
Which is a bit of a problem because he does love jumping.
So, like, when we play fetch...
When, like, I play fetch and I like, you know, throw the ball, he would jump to grab to catch the ball and stuff.
So, like, I gotta make sure he doesn't do that anymore.
Like...
So...
That's like the one thing I have to make sure he doesn't do when we play fetch.
Uh...
No more...
No more parkour for that little guy.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
I really...
Jumping has...
Has been revoked now.
And...
So, yeah.
But yes, thank you guys.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate you all being there for him.
And...
Um...
Want to know what's going on and everything.
I just hope that...
Like, if I have to, I will, like, take him to surgery.
If...
But that's, like, basically, like, the last resort type deal.
Like, you know.
And they did say it was early stages.
So...
Um...
As long as it's, like, you know, still early stages and everything.
It's mostly just rest and recovery.
And...
And he's gonna be, like, stuck in his little...
Um...
Pen and everything.
So, he's not gonna...
Uh...
He's not gonna be, like, moving anywhere.
From what I'm told.
Uh...
So, he's just gonna be, like, you know, in his little...
Little, like...
Like, stuck in the little pens.
Like, no moving!
From what, like, the black doctor's gonna tell me on how they're gonna do it.
I'm just really appreciative that they are, you know, willing to...
Like, the fact that they were willing to take care of him.
Last minute.
Literally, I, like, messaged them.
And I was like, hey, this is, like, an emergency.
And, um, I know, like, usually I need to, like, give you a heads up and stuff.
And they're like, we'll be there.
Like, instantly, they're like, yeah, like, um...
The...
The main doc says, like, yeah, my husband will...
We'll drive over right now to the vet.
And, like, we can pick him up and, uh, look after him.
While, like, you know, I thought I was like, I'm really...
This week is really bad timing because I love work stuff.
Uh, and then they instantly was like, we'll be there.
Um, we can pick him up, like, right now.
Like, we...
My husband will drive over to pick him up and everything.
And I was, like, really appreciative of that.
Because, usually, I need to give, like, heads up and stuff.
But they...
They also really love him.
Um, like, it was really funny because I, like, I had a really...
Um, I was really stressed out at work for work-related stuff.
So, um, I wanted him to, like, be...
I couldn't take care of dad at one point.
Like, I think, like, this was, like, a month or two ago.
And then I messaged him.
I was like, hey, I know, like, um...
I remember, like, a month or two ago.
I was just like, hey, um, do you have any openings this week?
Uh, to look after him.
And then the dog stare was instantly, like...
We cancelled our arrangement with the other owner because...
They, like...
The dog sitter messaged me back and was like, we love him.
We cancelled our other appointment with the other...
With the other, like, dog that we were supposed to dog sit.
Uh, so yeah, we could go pick him up whenever.
And I was like, oh my god, yippee!
So, the family really loves him as well.
Like, they always tell me, like, oh yeah, he's part of our family.
Like, he feels like he's part of our family as well.
Um, and like, uh, and that, like, you know, that, uh...
That makes me feel really happy that they love him as much as, like, you know, I love him as well.
So, uh, yeah.
He is the number one priority.
That's...
So, it is sort of like a second home, uh, to him.
And, uh, and you know, the family, the dog sitter loves him as much as me as well.
And, uh, they're like, yeah, he's like, he really is, like, a part of, like, their family as well as my family.
And, um, and I really appreciate that.
They literally, like, took him in instantly during the vet visit.
Like, when the husband came over at the vet, we still had to wait an additional, like, 40 minutes.
Um, for the medication and everything.
And for, uh, like, we had to wait, like, 15 minutes for dad to come out of the vet office.
And then another, like, we had to wait another, like, uh, 30 minutes.
And, like, he was waiting for 30 minutes with me.
And he was, like, you know, um, helping me look after him and, like, petting him and everything.
Making sure he's comfortable and everything.
And while we were waiting.
So, um, so it was really appreciative.
And then, you know, um, he was like, oh, let me Google.
And then I told him what's going on.
And he's like, okay, let me Google, like, what I can do around the house to make him feel more comfortable.
And, uh, so I really, yeah, I really appreciate that.
The fact that they were willing to come over on, like, you know, instantly.
Because, like, you know, I was worried that they were also, like, had to dog sit somebody else.
Since they're not just, like, they're not just, like, my dog sitter.
They're, like, other people's dog sitters, too.
And there was, like, no hesitation or anything.
And, um, that's why I felt like they were, like, one of the best dog sitters I've ever had.
And that's why they're very expensive, too.
So, thank you guys... so much!
I'd do anything for in that video & like, I really appreciate it too.
Aka, thank you for the AkaSuppa!
Thank you!
Zechra, thank you for the AkaSuppa!
Praying for dad's recovery!
he's a good dog!
Will maybe continue to be spoiled by the dog sitter.
Thank you!
Thank you for the AkaSuppa!
Thank you thank you!
Anyway, sorry, I change the topic...
I hope you guys enjoyed Nimi's debut.
I was watching Nimi's debut while waiting for my stream to start.
Just to pass the time.
Really cute.
I love her new skin suit.
It's incredibly cute.
She grew 10 feet tall.
Because I pushed my stream for her debut.
And it also let me zone out and disassociate for a little bit.
You know.
It was... I think my favorite part was when the Nappling started clapping.
I was like, oh my god, please clap.
And it was like... I thought that was so fucking cute.
It just... I don't know.
I think that was my favorite part of the entire debut.
It was just the fact that the little Nappling was just like...
That's really... Yeah, clapping was incredibly fucking hilarious.
And that was my favorite part of the entire...
Just the little guy clapping.
I don't know.
There's just something about it.
It just makes me so happy.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'll be finishing this game today.
Because apparently what you guys told me, the last level is really, really, really, really hard.
So, I'm like, really, really scared about the last level.
So, I'm not gonna push myself to...
I'm not gonna push myself to stream... to finish the game and everything.
And, oh yeah, another, like... Okay, it's not funny.
But, like, um...
But, like, I found out that... You know how, like, the Pope died on Easter?
And then, like... You know how I found out about it?
I didn't realize the Pope had a fandom.
Like, an actual, like, Twitter fandom.
And what do you mean by that, Doki?
Well, I found out about it because, like...
One of, like, the main fan artists for the Pope was, like, freaking out about it.
And I was like, the Pope has fan artists?
Yeah!
There's, like, an active fandom for the Pope.
And, like, literally, this is, like, one of the most well-known fan artists of the Pope.
And, like, all she draws is, like, Pope art.
And I was...
I was... Or he... I don't know.
But, like, um...
That's, like, all they draw.
And I was, like, looking through it.
And I was, like, oh, my God.
Like...
No!
It's, like, you know, like...
You know how fandoms have, like, fan artists?
You know, like, also, like, how I have fan artists?
So, like, the Pope... Like, the Catholic...
There's, like, not just the Pope, but, like...
I guess, like, the Catholic...
The Vatican City fandom?
I... I don't know.
I don't know what to call it!
It's...
The Vatican City fandom?
So, I was very surprised.
Cause, like...
You know, obviously the...
The one of the most...
Well-known fan artists for it was, like, freaking out.
It was, like, oh, my God.
Like...
I can't believe...
He passed away.
And then...
No!
Okay!
No, you don't understand.
Okay, I'll show one of the fan art.
Like...
Cause I was, like...
What?
Like...
Um...
This is, like, how I...
Found out...
About...
Um...
How I found out about the fandom.
And how I found out that, like...
The Pope died.
Like...
I...
Oh, my God.
But...
Like...
This is what I...
This is...
This is what I mean.
Like...
You can get their art prints and everything.
So...
I love, like...
Beloved My John.
Like...
I was just like...
Oh, my God!
Um...
Yeah, that...
That's how I found out.
Uh...
I was like...
Oh, my God!
I didn't realize they have...
They have...
Um...
I didn't realize they have a huge fandom fight.
And I was...
I thought that was really interesting.
I was, like...
Going into the glimpse of, like...
The other side.
Like...
Um...
And everything.
And...
Yeah, so...
That's how I found out.
Also, like...
The...
The fact that, like...
Twitter is, like, campaigning which Pope they want to be elected as if, like, their vote...
As if...
There's a campaign.
Or...
I...
I don't know if you also saw that.
But there's, like...
There's, like, Twitter campaigns for, like, whichever Pope they want to, like...
to like, you know, succeed the the last pope and but then it's like, but I don't think they know that like, that's not how the next pope is elected.
I don't think they realize that's how, that's how the pope elections work.
Um, the Vatican's next top pope.
Like, so I was, I saw on Twitter, um, I saw on Twitter where like, someone was like, we gotta get this guy, and like, guys, we have to vote for this guy, and I was like, I don't think they realize how, how, how popes are selected.
Um, um, looking at the pope elections.
Uh, Parapol, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I think when the pope came to Japan, he wore, oh yeah, no, he did, I saw it!
It was like an anime drawing of the pope, and then like, um, he's gonna, he's like, literally the only pope that has listened to Megalovania, and like, been exposed to Sans Undertale.
Because of the game theory?
What was it?
Game theory gave, uh, the pope, uh, Megalov, like, uh, like, the, the soundtrack of, um, Undertale or something?
Yeah, MatPat did that.
MatPat gave him, like, the soundtrack for Undertale, and made him listen to Megalovania.
Like, like, that's when it all started.
Uh, but yes, thank you, guys, super chat, thank you, thank you.
Anyway, let's play Simpsons!
Sorry, this is a long ass, we, we, it's been an hour, I didn't realize.
Oh my gosh, sorry, guys.
Let's actually get to the real gameplay.
But it, it was nice to just, you know, talk with you guys after the very stressful, stressful day.
Um, but you guys always make me feel a lot better and everything.
Alright, let me see, let me see what, I have to make sure, okay, the sound is okay.
Uh, but yeah, thank you guys for listening to me ramble on, um, today.
I really appreciate it, guys, it does help a lot, and gets my mind off things.
Anyway, let's go back to the Simpsons!
Resume game.
I think we're at March now?
I'm pretty sure.
Bum-ba-dum!
Wait.
Oh yeah, I was like, no, don't get, put me back.
I was gonna be like, no, you can't do this to me.
Don't put me back here.
But I forgot, I came back for Florida.
I, I was like, I can't do this, I'm not strong enough.
I literally got back from the vet, please.
I'm not strong enough for this.
I- All right.
Talk to me, son.
Hello?
Son, talk to... Oh my god, no.
Why is my son not talking to me?
Please.
Oh, eh.
Are you okay?
Oh, no!
Not Google!
Hands?
Crop circles?
There's got... Aliens!
It's always aliens.
All right.
Let's see.
Find Chief Wiggum and collect donuts for him before time runs out.
Wait, what?
Why?
Does he only accept payment in donuts?
All right.
Do you guys know they gave Chief Wiggum's wife, like, a personality now?
Which is crazy, because she was, like, literally just his plus one.
And then they, like, made him, like, made her, like, like, a spy.
Like, no, like, what was it?
They made her a scam artist or some fucking shit?
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
No!
I didn't know it's times right now!
I'll do my best.
Yeah, she's, like, uh, she's, like, uh, spy slash heist person or whatever.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to remember how... Guys, I don't remember the controls.
All right, here we go.
We're... Okay.
It's okay.
I'm... Easy cut.
No!
Why did it end so fast?
I just got in the car!
Like, excuse me, I'm... How fast?
How much faster do you want me to be?
Oh, just because I hit one car, I've lost a game.
I...
Please!
Wiggum, where are you going?
What is this difficulty?
Oh, no.
What is this difficulty, Spike?
Okay.
Guys, guys, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I used a shortcut.
I forgot about the shortcut.
All right.
Here we go.
It's fine.
I used a shortcut.
Now I'm in front of him.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
No.
Not even.
Even with the shortcut.
No, please.
Slow down.
Wiggum!
Where are you... Where are you going?
Oh, he's going to the Lard Donut.
Lard Lad.
Okay.
I need to... I don't remember where Lard Lad is.
Oh, it's right here.
All right.
Okay.
I'm gonna... explore.
All right.
I can... What is... Why is she running like this?
Okay.
Now that I know she's over there... Wait.
This is just Homer's level.
Wait.
I don't get a new level area?
That's so lazy.
I can't believe it.
That's so lazy in 2003 or whatever, whenever this game came out.
I can't believe they couldn't fit more levels.
In 2003, they really phoned it in, guys.
But it's night time, Doki.
I can't believe it.
All right.
Let's see.
Did I get everything here?
I definitely need more coins.
All right.
Let's see.
I want more coins just in case.
I don't know if she has, like, actually good clothes, though.
Good cosmetic outfits.
But we'll see.
Oh, hey.
Is that Moe?
Wait, no.
That's not Moe.
That's...
She's in a dress.
Is there anything...
Anything around here?
That might be...
That might be interesting for me to go.
Why does Marge run like that?
Look.
She's going through a lot, okay?
She has three kids that'll never grow up.
And one of them's a baby.
And...
I think that's the worst part.
None of them are self-sufficient children.
Having three kids really slows you down.
Yep.
Oh, my God.
Marge, that's exactly what I said.
Don't worry, Marge.
I got you.
I'm here for you.
That's exactly what I said.
I swear I used to be a better runner.
Oh, true.
And Homer.
I forgot about that.
All right, let's go back to Chief Wiggum.
All right, Chief.
I don't know.
I think like...
Oh, I feel like really bad for the voice actress for Marge.
Because it's just...
She sounds...
She...
I feel like...
Do you know they retired Milhouse?
Milhouse is retired now as a character.
Because the voice actor retired.
Or voice actress retired for him.
I don't remember if it was a guy or girl that voices him.
But like, Marge now is like really sad to hear.
Yeah.
There's got to be a...
Aw, that's cute.
I'd love to help.
But I got sugar withdrawal real bad.
The donut store is closed.
And I got a monkey on my back screaming for Kruller.
Oh.
Oh, he's screaming.
Wait, why do you have a monkey back there?
Wiggum?
Hit the donut truck?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Where is he?
All right, don't worry, chief.
I'll commit crime for you.
If I'm committing crime for the cops, it's legal.
All right, don't worry.
Don't worry.
The cops want me to do this.
I'm doing it for the sake of the police.
Where's your donut?
Where's the item?
Okay, I'll grab that later.
All right, this is bad.
I think I already failed it.
Oh my god.
I forgot about this.
Oh, please.
Oh, I should have got the...
Wait, give me a sec.
I know what to do.
All right, give me a sec, donut man.
It's time.
It's time for Mr. Plow.
Don't worry.
I got a real car now.
Mr. Plow, that's my name.
Wait, where did he go?
Hello, donut man?
Whoa, shit.
Donut man, where are you?
Wait, why is he over there?
Jump the ramp.
Why are you scared?
Boom.
Wait, did that work?
Wait, I clouded you.
Oh, shit.
Guys, can you tell that I haven't played in a while?
Oh, please.
Get over here.
I need an idea.
Please.
I need the donut.
Oh, my God.
I can't.
I need a restart.
Please, just give me a restart.
I can't right now.
I'm not okay.
Please.
Give me a restart.
Wait, stone cutters.
Oh, shit.
It's the stone cutters.
Oh, my God.
Wait, the stone cutters want some donuts as well?
Okay.
Free money.
Yay.
Oh, fuck.
All right.
Mr. Plot might be a little too big.
Is he...
Is...
Are they actually recasting Milhouse?
I thought they were retiring the character.
Like, they retired.
Um...
Because they retired...
Another character got retired because the voice actor was like...
Wait, do I have to do...
Are you serious?
I have to go to Marjland again?
Oh, my...
Okay, I know when I fucked around.
Oh, no.
We did.
You know, I have the Simpsons soundtrack on my phone.
I actually bought, like, um...
Well, it's like the Simpsons best hits.
I have the Simpsons movie soundtrack and, like, the Simpsons TV show soundtrack.
Oh, please.
Why?
Why do I have to do this again?
It's okay.
He's...
He sits here.
No!
Wait, what's up, Mr. Plow?
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you, Chief.
Legally enforced violence.
That's my favorite part.
Boom.
All right.
Nice.
I just need to take him to the corner.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
No!
Give me that one donut!
Get over here!
The cops gave me the right of law!
Wait, where's my donut?
Dude, where's my donut?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Come on, I'm at three.
I'm always halfway.
Give me my donut.
Nice.
Come on.
Donut!
Where is he going?
Oh, shit.
I thought he was gonna go left.
Oh!
Oh, no!
Wait, I can still hit him.
That's allowed.
Okay, nice.
And then...
Fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll just stop here.
He has to hit me.
Never mind.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Two more.
That's right!
Thank you, garbage man!
Boom!
Oh.
Yay!
Wait, I have to drive back?
Trash?
Wait!
It doesn't TP!
I did my job!
How are you so hungry?
Wait, go!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
It's not that far.
It's not that far from home.
We're driving slow and steady in my hit and run.
Okay, this way.
The cops don't really want to catch me yet because I still have like three more hits.
I have...
All right, following traffic laws right now.
I do not want to...
Oh, no.
Guys, I can't get caught.
I can't go back.
I can't go back, guys.
I'm a law-abiding citizen.
All right, where is it?
It's that far?
There's no way I drove that far.
Oh, shit, no.
Oh, no, I panicked a little bit.
Oh, my God.
No, there's 33.
No, don't hit me!
Don't hit me!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Everything's fine.
Yay!
We did it!
I didn't get hit.
I can't go back to prison, guys.
Please.
Boy, for a busybody housewife, you sure get results.
That crop circles at Cletus's shack.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I have a truck full of donuts to eat.
I'm gonna need a lot of coffee.
Wait, I needed to ask Wiggum where the crop circle was?
Just read the news.
Oh, wait.
Surely it's a...
It's...
It's Springfield.
You don't have that much shit going on.
All right, let me grab some more coins.
You used to be a cop, Marge.
You should be able to do this detective work without Wiggum.
All right, let me grab...
Oh, nice.
We need this.
Get over here.
No, no, no, no!
My coins!
It's okay.
I can get the coins back.
Oh, I can almost afford an outfit.
I can't afford too close for you, Marge!
You don't have to shop at the bargain bin anymore!
Oh, is in-game volume low?
Okay, don't worry, guys.
I need a long island iced tea.
Let me fix the volume real quick for you guys.
Uh, sound...
Oh, did every...
No, nothing reset.
I was like...
I thought the stuff...
Oh.
Uh...
Let me up it a little bit for us.
That's weird.
I put up the old volume from before.
I'll up it up a little bit.
All right, let me know what's better, guys.
Also, sound guys here.
I don't know.
Sound guys didn't say anything.
All right.
I should save.
Don't leave me.
I should really save.
It's not been a very lucky month for me.
All right.
Uh, where's my car?
Where's my car?
Wait.
Wait, what can I buy here?
The Quicking Mart.
Oh, everything reset itself because it's like Marge's level and not Homer's.
I just realized.
Let me in.
Do I have anything at the Quicking Mart?
The last time you'll hear a poo.
What grubber chow do you have?
Perhaps this curry pixie stick will suit your fancy.
Oh, hey.
There's Mo Man.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, free money.
Yippee!
My $1!
All right.
Let's see.
What can I buy?
Three hundred dollars to be in Florida?
Oh, it's the classy mo- Oh my god, it's- Oh my god, I told him- If I'm the cop, if I'm the police, I'll never be arrested.
You can't arrest me if I'm the cop.
I have three hundred dollars to fucking pay to jail.
Can I steal the death truck?
No fun.
Give me your money.
I should be able to rob him.
I should be legally allowed to rob these people.
All right.
What?
Damn.
That's not true, look at me now.
Yeah, it was- If woman drivers aren't very good, what do you explain this?
What do you mean this?
Okay, let me grab- Oh, I don't care about that enough.
Wait, what's this?
Wait, I can go to this room?
Wait, how do I do that?
Oh, okay.
That's not how you do it.
Oh, I could go into Bart's room.
Mommy's here.
Oh, that's so cool.
There's like little Easter eggs and everything in Bart's room.
Too bad he has nothing in here because we're poor.
We're broke.
Actually, like, Homer's the richest millennial I've ever known.
Being able to afford for three children and also like two cars and a house in suburbia.
He's living the life.
And he works at a nuclear power plant.
Like, what the fuck?
Please, where is he?
I don't have... I don't know!
My depth perception isn't working!
Oh my god, give me a sec, guys.
I'm trying to figure out...
No, my coins!
All right, there we go.
We don't talk about Bart and Simpson.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Homer is the millennial of all boomers expected by Simpy.
Oh no, they're about to get raptured.
No, modern Simpsons equals Homer is a millennial now.
Hello, knock knock.
Yes, get ready to get raptured, Ned.
Genuflecting?
The fuck is that?
I need more step aerobics.
Finally, my videotape of Christian Vegetables is here.
Christian Vegetables?
Videota...
Oh, VeggieTales!
I was like, the fuck is Christian?
I forgot VeggieTales!
VeggieTales!
I used to love VeggieTales.
Broccoli!
Celery!
Bum-ba-dum!
VeggieTales!
I didn't realize it was based off like religion until I got older.
I just thought they were like silly vegetables.
I should have realized this when they did a tale about like Noah.
Oh yeah!
I realized it was like about like religion when they start- When I watched the- Because I bought the movie DVD of the Noah's art.
Was it Noah or the one- The one with the whale?
No, it wasn't Noah.
It was the one where he got- Uh, Larry got eaten by a whale.
And I realized, wait, is this religion?
Is this- Oh, Jonah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I bought the DVD for Jonah and I was like, oh my god, wait a minute.
This is about- This is about God!
Oh, hey comic book guy!
Oh, whoops!
What did he want me to do?
I skipped it.
Click all the intercepted gifts, don't let time run out.
I like that I really- It's cause like I really enjoyed the- the songs.
The silly songs.
So I never fully realized that, um...
Oh wait, I'm gonna get the Kremlin!
I didn't realize it was about God.
I just thought the silly songs were cool.
Alright, let's get- Let me get Abe here.
Alright, I don't remember where- I have to go to where again?
Wait, where's Abe?
Oh, I have to drive to the school.
I actually- No, I skipped the dial!
If I fail the mission- Wait, actually, I just gotta leave the mission.
So you have a shortcut.
I hope there's not much more.
Abe, where are you?
Where did he go?
I thought he was gonna drive for me!
Wait, how do I cancel mission?
Oh, I can!
Okay, let's listen to the- Yeah.
I'm sure.
Okay, I'll come back.
Alright, I want to know what the dialogue was.
I actually pressed skip.
And now it's time for Silly Songs with Larry.
The part of the show where Larry comes out and sing a silly song.
Exactly!
I thought it was just Silly Vegetables!
I didn't realize they were preaching!
I- I- Ha ha ha ha!
Lexi, thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I like the water buffalo song.
Alright, hello!
Time for some foot-on payment action!
Alright, comic book, what did you actually want me to do?
Mr. Guy, what are you doing here?
Well, I've been trying to convince Agnes to come make fun of school children, but she refuses to go out with me.
That son of hers keeps intercepting every gift I send her and hides them at his workplace.
He's a jerk and a fool.
Why not just go get them back?
I would, but...
Well, I'm not a terribly mobile person.
There, I said it.
Wait, what?
It's not easy being hustled.
Is he dating Agnes?
Tell you what, I'll take you to ask me.
Oh my god, cougar!
What a fucking cougar!
I forgot that...
I forgot back then.
Comic book guy was dating Agnes before he got...
uh, hot Japanese wife.
I forgot...
Oh my god!
I didn't realize he was a freak like that.
I didn't realize he was a gilf.
For a comic book guy, he does have a lot of game.
Okay, I don't...
I don't know that's beyond hags, guys.
Seymour is like 50 or some shit right now.
I gotta go...
Go to the school.
And pick her up.
All right, let's see...
Where the fuck is the school?
I've driven around Springfield so many times, I still can't like...
I still can't like process where everything is.
I might not be very good at directions.
Just a maybe.
Hey!
Hey, wait a minute, you hit me!
Where's your insurance?
Oh wait, what?
Oh, these are the gifts?
Oh, shit, okay.
But where are the rest of the gifts?
Wait, what?
Wait, I didn't know!
I didn't know!
The child was on me!
The child fucking stood in front of my car!
How the fuck was I supposed to- How the fuck was I supposed to- She stood in front of my car!
It was that my fault that she happened to be at the playground!
How was that my fault?
Drive to me!
The child walked in front of my speeding vehicle!
She was committing insurance fraud!
Look at that!
Get out of the way, child!
Oh no, I have to do this mission again because of this child.
It's all his fault.
Wait, is that underwear?
Is that edible underwear?
No.
No, we're so close!
No, I have to do a jump!
We were so close!
No!
Wait a minute.
Okay, I can drive back there.
That's fine.
Alright.
Those are great gifts.
He's speaking from experience.
Wouldn't, like, edible underwear be, like, sticky?
Like, what kind of- Like, what is it made out of?
I feel like that'd be so uncomfortable.
Like, please.
Don't keep stop.
Like, I'm saying, like, what- What is edible, like, underwear even made of?
Oh, shit.
No, it's fine.
I have two more tries.
Copper, I told you!
The child was committing insurance fraud!
She stood in front of my car!
Okay, it's over here.
All right, collect the number of gifts.
Okay, we got her a pair of new dentures.
And then, we gotta go into the Springfield Elementary School.
All right, there's Willie!
Hey, Willie!
Wait, Willie got married, too!
I feel like the new plot line for, like, um, for, like, Modern Simpsons is that everybody's just getting married right now.
Yeah, he's- he got married to, like, he's apparently, like, some fucking prodigy was sniffing out truffles or some shit.
And then, like, the plot line is that, um, the plot line of the- Oh, shit.
Sorry, I need to figure out where the other- where his other gifts are.
Wait, I'm missing, like, where is it?
Where's the last gift?
Wait, where is it?
Oh, no, let's do this again.
Oh, no, I don't know where the last one is.
Wait, where is it?
Is it Buzz?
Wait, where- Oh, it's the other side of the roof!
Oh, no!
Oh, I'm blind!
I'm fucking- I didn't realize it was also on the roof!
No, I can't jump!
How do I get there?
How do I parkour?
Wait, how do I get to the roof?
Oh, my God!
The gamers don't know how- I don't know how to get up there!
Oh, I was on the wrong side.
Okay.
Okay, but yeah, the entire plot line of the- Guys, I actually watch Modern Simpsons because, like, um, I'm all about the brain rot.
Um, um, um, but, like, I am a connoisseur of, like, um, animated- animated TV shows.
So I actually watch, like, uh, actually watch Modern Simpsons, so I'm, like- I caught up to, like, the last two or three seasons of Modern Simpsons.
So, yeah, the- most of the newer plot lines of Modern Simpsons is, like, a lot of your favorite Simpsons characters are, like, now married or have, like, kids or something.
And, um, I remember it's, like, what was it?
Oh, and then Flanders is now severely depressed.
That's- that's the best I could describe it.
Like, Flanders' new character development is that he's just incredibly depressed now.
Um, like, you know how he's, like, howdy-loo, neighborino, and all of them, like, you know, I love my family, and, like, God.
But now, like, now he's just incredibly fucking depressed.
Like, I mean, to be fair, both his wives did die.
So, like, you know, you can't really be happy anymore about that.
But, like, every new storyline they do with Flanders, he's just, like, he's not okay.
He- at one point, he became, like, some sort of, like, um...
Okay, wait, let me- No!
At one point, he became, like, like, um, like a fugitive or something.
They had, like, this weird-ass storyline with Flanders, where, like, he became a fugitive because his dad...
You know, like, before, they're, like, oh yeah, his dad's a hippie.
And then they, like...
Wait, where- where is it?
Oh.
And then they, like, um...
What's the word called?
They, like, retconned it, and now his dad is, like, a police officer, but, like, a corrupted police officer.
So, like, I- I don't know why they- they retconned that.
Like, you know, his dad was supposed to be a fucking hippie, but now it's not.
Like, like, his dad is now, uh, a corrupted police officer.
And, uh, I know I'm still on a timer.
Don't worry, I can get there.
I'm gonna get there in time.
Oh, was it his grandpa?
No, it wasn't- it was his grandpa.
Oh, his grandpa!
Okay.
His grandpa is now- his grandpa is a corrupted- Oh my god, I didn't realize it was his grandpa, because he- his grandpa was so fucking young.
Oh yeah, so they retconned the fact that his grandpa is a corrupted police officer now.
Um, who- I thought it was his dad.
I thought that was, like, talking about his dad.
Um.
But, yeah, and then, like, they had, like, this really weird storyline- Oh no, I think- guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
Oh no.
Guys- guys, why did you stop it?
Guys!
Why did you stop it?
I thought I had time!
I- It's not my fault.
Okay, okay, this time- I can do that.
This time I'll pay attention.
I was following traffic laws!
It's not my fault!
You- you just seem really confident, Dookie.
I- I- I- I- I- I failed the yap.
Why is he so far?
If you wanna see your- your guilt, you gotta move closer to home.
Look, you're right.
It's not my- it's not your fault.
It's our fault, okay?
Look, we share the blame together.
It's our channel.
Okay.
There we go.
Seijian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, we got this.
This is a group effort.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
I just gotta park my car.
Don't worry, Willy.
Don't worry.
This is a very important mission.
For the- wait, how did he get over there?
You're right.
This is Vladimir's fault.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should have drove around for this.
I forgot how slow- How slow I am.
Oh no.
We're so fine.
Don't worry.
Everything is fine.
I might have- I should have parked a little closer again.
I might have fucked up by not parking a little closer.
But yeah, anyway.
In that episode, he like was running from- Like, it got like super fucking weird.
Because it got like- They were parodying- What was it called?
Uh- Fargo or some shit?
Yeah, they were parodying the Fargo.
Fargo episode.
Wait, is there like a phone- Telephone booth there?
Yes, there is.
Okay, I can just call another car.
I need more step aerobics classes.
Okay, nice.
Uh...
What's fast?
What's the fast- What car do I have that's fast?
Oh, I'm going backwards.
Okay.
My Malibu Stacy car.
All right, Lisa.
Some people are famous for their ability to drive from an early age.
All right, see, I told you.
Now women drivers aren't bad, Marge.
Nice girls.
Finish fast.
See, look at that.
We're fast, but we might not be the best drivers, but we're fast.
Okay.
Wait, the timer- The timing didn't stop was looking through cards!
I just realized!
I was like- I thought I had a long time!
I didn't even know what car to get!
I- Oh, no.
Can I say you guys want to try this?
You guys want to do this again?
How the fuck was I supposed- Oh, no.
Oh, no.
And I'm going to get gold!
No, my money!
No!
And- I got- My money!
And I lost $50!
$50!
It's not fair.
Oh my god, I made it!
Wait, it got me closer!
It got me closer to the objective!
Oh my god!
Speedrun!
Speedrun tech!
Tactical arrest!
Peta win!
Let's go!
Oh, guys.
It was intentional.
Guys, like I said, everything is always intentional, guys.
Let's go!
Peta win!
I love Peta win!
Any episode of Simpsons that made you cry or at least emotional?
Um...
I'm trying to remember.
There was- There was a Simpsons episode that really, really- I think- I think it's when- It's a Flanders episode.
It's when he started getting more depressed.
Um...
It's- Um, for those who, like- It's- It's actually the modern- It's one of the modern Simpsons episodes.
And, like, it's the one where there's, like, clips of it.
Some of you guys might have seen the- Some of you guys might have seen the clips of it, but it was when he talks about how it's harder to believe- believe in God because, like, he keeps having really fucked up things happening to him.
And, like, you know, how his two wives have died and stuff like that.
So...
Um...
But that's, like, one of my- my favorite- Like, that's one of my- not favorite episodes, but one of my more emotional episodes that really, like- Alright, let's go- I need to go- buy clothes.
I gotta be a cop.
Yeah, that one.
That one was, like, one of my, like, more emotional episodes.
Yeah, that one was, like, so touchy-feely.
And then, any ep- any episode- And if I wanna say, like, my favorite classic Simpson episodes that, like- that are, like- Well, not like, but, like, more, like, made me very emotional was- Yeah, I'm driving backwards because I need to buy my clothes.
I need to buy clothes.
I need to be a cop.
It's when, um- Which one was it?
It's when, uh- Homer, uh- Um- Wait, Homer's mom left him again.
That one was really- That one was a good episode.
Alright.
Let's go buy a clothes.
Yeah, the one where Homer's- Homer's mom dies.
I hate the- I hate the episodes where they bring her back in the modern Simpsons.
Those ones, I don't like.
And they, like, retcon it.
They're like, Here's another way that Homer's mom disappeared.
Even though, like, you know, they never- I don't like that they kept trying to add, like, more storyline to Homer's mom.
Because I felt like the way it ended was, like, the best way it could have ended.
Alright.
They can't catch- I can't get arrested if I'm a cop.
They didn't, like, retcon- They didn't retcon her.
They more, like, they tried to add more storylines to her right after she died.
And I didn't like that.
Alright.
Let's go back to Cletus.
Gonna have my daughter drive me to- Guys, it's perfectly legal.
See, she has a designated driver next to her.
She's getting her learner's permit.
She's so- She's, like- You know how she's so smart?
She has the IQ of, like, at least, like, a 20-year-old.
So I'm, like, her- Like, you know, like, learner's permit where you have a guardian next to you?
It's okay.
Mentally.
Mentally, she's at least 20.
So it's perfectly legal.
And her mom's a cop.
Would a cop do illegal things?
It's not a crime!
Marge actually was a cop!
It's not her fault that she kept the uniform!
Alright.
Hello, Cletus.
Excuse me?
I don't care if you is from New York.
You ain't taking pictures of our decrappitude for no magazine, no way.
No, Cletus, it's me!
It's me, Marge!
Marge!
Follow Cletus and collect what flowers from...
Don't miss any...
Wait, what is he collecting?
Where's Cletus?
Oh, he's back here!
Oh, shit!
Whoops!
Alright, I had to run her over.
You ha- You don't understand.
She was in the way- Oh my god!
Get out of the way!
I'm trying to run over somebody!
Perfectly legal, though.
Perfectly legal.
I'm a cop.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god, he's so far.
He's actually so far away.
Where did he go?
He's so...
Alright.
It's fine.
I don't know.
Oh, I had to follow and collect his stuff?
So I can't...
He can't, like, be gone.
Wait, why didn't you drop anything?
I hit you.
Oh, wait.
What?
He's dropping...
Oh, wait!
He's dropping stuff on his own!
I don't have to hit him!
You shouldn't enjoy that.
Okay, that's good.
He's...
He's leaving, like, a little breadcrumbe trail for me.
Yeah, it dropped...
I just noticed it drops randomly.
I was like, how did it...
How did he drop stuff?
Without me doing anything.
Come on.
Drop it.
I need some road ready.
I'm right here.
Drop it.
Stay here.
Wait, wait.
If I...
Okay.
I can't leave now.
I can't leave.
I can't.
Just drop it.
Just drop...
What?
That's illegal!
Wait, what the...
How did he do that?
How did he...
How did he fucking do that?
Aliens.
What the fuck?
That's cheating!
Oh, no.
I'm backwards.
He no-clipsed.
I thought I had him.
The redneck magic.
Alright.
This time.
This time I got this.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, it's cola!
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'm right here.
Bro, face through reality.
Are we in a video game?
There's no way.
I thought this is real life.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
He dropped apples.
Wait.
No.
He's just dropping random shit.
This is the fat guy.
This is the fat...
My child's car is the fastest car I own, guys.
Alright.
Nice.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure Mr. Burns has insurance.
Right, guys?
The richest man in Springfield surely has provided good healthcare for his employees.
Is he just grocery shopping?
I'm just picking up his groceries right now.
Ha!
Aww.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I am so totally embarrassed.
Are you okay, Clintus?
Wait.
What if I lock him in again?
There you go.
You can't...
Can't get...
There you go.
Nice girls finish face.
Oh, no.
I fucked up again.
I...
It's okay.
I can drive backwards.
That's fine.
This works.
Oh, no.
No.
Why did I decide to be cocky?
Wait.
This is fixable.
This is so fixable.
Come back here.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Where is he?
Clintus, where are you?
Just please.
Hit something.
Anything.
Oh, no.
He's driving well now.
It's okay.
I'll grab that item back later.
I'll grab it later.
It's okay.
I'll grab...
No!
I thought I could grab it later.
Alright.
It's okay.
I learned now.
I'm not cocky anymore.
I love the hardcore banjo.
During this day, give us a super chat.
Thank you.
Tokyo, are you so...
Thank you, guys.
Do you guys notice how good I am at video games?
Breezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can tell, like, at what point in my life where I didn't play these certain games.
Where I didn't grow up with certain games, guys.
You can, you can tell exactly where I was at that point on the life.
I never played both of that tax...
I never played, like, taxi games or, like, any sort of, like, driving games back in the day.
I...
You can tell exactly where it started.
The crazy taxi...
I actually never grew up with crazy taxi.
I grew up with, like, my dad's video games and, like, all he used, all he played was just, like, shooters.
Like, Call of Duty, Medal of Honor.
Anything that's related to the wars.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'm not fucking around this time.
I figured it out.
But that's why I love streaming.
I love streaming so I can, like, experience this, this part of my life, this part of life that I never got to experience growing up.
Because I know there's, like, a lot of, like, childhood games for everybody.
Let's get harder, Doki.
This still isn't the worst of it.
That's why, like, streaming has led me, like, play games I never had a chance to play growing up.
She was a TF2.
I was...
Okay, no, that's...
That's a lie.
I was in the TM Fortress 2 fandom.
But I didn't, like...
I never played the game of Team Fortress 2.
Like, I played, like...
I...
Oh, no.
I fucked around.
It's okay.
Cletus.
Cletus is still driving nice and slow, right, Cletus?
Cletus, wait, hold up.
Cletus, Cletus.
No!
I didn't have a lap...
I didn't have a gaming PC or a gaming laptop.
So when I tried to play Team Fortress 2 with, like, the orange box.
When I...
When I had the orange box.
Um...
Oh, my God.
I'm back here.
Yay!
Tourist!
When I had the orange box.
And I tried to install...
Install it on my...
Um...
P...
Lap...
My laptop.
It wasn't a gaming laptop.
So I got, like...
And I wasn't really a gamer back then.
I tried to play on touchpad.
I...
I have to help me.
I have to find out what happened to my baby boy.
I'm sorry.
I thought you was a city slicker.
But I ain't telling you nothing.
Listen, you help us with the harvest.
Harvest?
The harvest?
I'm going to be doing...
Yeah, I tried to play Team Fortress 2 on touchpad.
Don't get your clothes dirty.
Purchase March...
No!
Wait.
I have to buy...
I have to legally be...
Pay money to be in...
Just arrest me.
Just fucking arrest me.
It's the same thing.
Like, why do I have to pay to be in jail?
Just...
Just put me in jail.
I know you played...
Spyro the Dragon.
But have you ever played other cool platformer classics?
Like...
Crash Bandicoot.
I played Crash Bandicoot.
I loved the Crash Bandicoot when I was growing up.
Um...
I had, like, the Spyro games.
And also...
I played almost all the Spyro games.
Even the bad ones.
Like, if you guys remember...
Some of the really bad Spyro games.
Where, like...
Sparks...
Sparks started...
Sparks was voiced by Ligia Wood.
And he was super fucking buff.
And, um...
He was super fucking buff.
And he was able to talk and stuff.
I played even those Spyro games.
I played every single iteration of Spyro.
Except for Skylanders.
Because fuck Skylanders.
I'm sorry.
Like...
Like, I did not want...
I did not want my Spyro to have...
To be ugly.
I...
I also bought the...
I also played the Cinderverse games too.
The Spyro when he had a girlfriend.
Or has a girlfriend.
Can't believe I had to pay...
To go to jail.
Can't believe it.
I can't just wear my cop clothes.
I never played Sky...
I know a lot of people love Skylanders.
But, like...
They...
They ruined Spyro for me.
Like, I couldn't...
I couldn't deal with that.
Not my Spyro.
Okay.
Get into the car.
Alright.
Cletus.
Help Cletus harvest ketchup packets for the...
Winter!
Just go to Krusty...
Just go to, like...
Krusty Burger.
Why not to harvest them?
It was so ugly in Skylander.
Yeah.
And then they made Crash Bandicoot talk.
It was so weird.
Alright.
Don't worry, Cletus.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
I have...
I'm timed?
Who's timing me?
The ketchup police?
Yeah.
They made him Australian.
Alright.
Here we go.
The slowest ramp jump of my life.
Alright.
There's a lot of dumpsters around here somewheres.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Why is your car so...
Why were you so fast when I had to chase you?
But you're so slow now.
Wee.
I don't understand.
Oh, my God.
Leave.
Get out.
Alright.
Nice.
Here we go.
Here.
Wee.
I'm flying like a turkey.
Oh, no.
It's this way.
It's okay.
Okay.
But it's your fault for standing in my way, children.
I'm not out of touch.
It's the children's fault.
Okay.
It's this way.
I'm gonna make it, right?
No, I will.
Alright.
I just need to drive a little faster now.
Where the fuck is the other ketchup?
Where is it?
Wait.
Where the fuck...
Where's the other ketchup?
Guys.
I might not make it.
I...
Where the fuck is the other ketchup?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Where is it?
Is it up here?
Oh, my God.
It's up a fucking ramp.
How was I supposed to...
Oh, my God.
I was supposed to make it.
I...
I was supposed to...
Okay.
This is like the slowest...
The slowest...
I can't get driving of my life.
It's not my fault.
It's Sakaar's fault, guys.
Guys.
I swear to God.
It's not me.
It's Sakaar.
I swear to God.
Here we go.
Alright.
There we go.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
He didn't ketchup.
Alright.
But sometimes it's not a stunt.
How was I supposed to do?
Here we go.
Yeah.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
You drive right!
Okay.
It's okay.
I figured this out.
I know the route now.
Yippee!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This has to be...
This car is actually so hard to drive.
I don't understand.
He was so fast before.
He was...
How are you so fast before?
Oh, my God.
I barely made that jump.
Okay.
Come on.
Make the jump.
Make the...
No!
How did I miss?
I was driving.
I followed the ramp.
Are you serious?
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Oh, no.
My car is about to explode.
Don't... I hit one thing and my guy... and my guy is about to slow.
Guys, okay, I'm gonna... No, no, I will not go around the point!
You can't bait me!
Just go around!
Don't you just... Just go around!
How do you...
Guys, it's not my fault.
It's the car.
It's like how Marge... Go around!
Guys, you're just like Marge.
You don't believe in me.
I'm basically Homer, and you're the wife that doesn't believe in me.
Marge!
I just need a supportive wife to believe in me.
This is why... This is why Homer...
This is why Homer can't, like, reach his potential.
Marge never believes in him.
Real and true.
Why can't you believe in me?
Alright.
Nice.
Look at that.
Look at that stunt that I just performed.
You wish you could do that.
I didn't fail!
It was the car's fault!
It's not a fail, and it's, like, not my fault.
Whee!
This time...
I got the momentum!
Woo!
Oh my god, I made it!
Oh!
I told you!
You just gotta believe!
Why couldn't you just believe?
Oh wait, I'm in...
Wait, Mr. Burr...
I go to Mr. Burr's house?
Nice.
Okay, and then I left Mr. Burr's house.
Oh, is this back to...
Oh wait, it's this human chessboard!
Wait, is this back to, like...
Um...
Oh wait, this is, like, secret!
Wait, how do I...
How do I get there?
Wait...
What?
Oh my god...
Wait, how do I get there?
Wait, no!
That is...
Wait...
No.
No!
There was a turd!
I just...
Oh my...
Turd!
I can't believe it.
Okay.
This is fine.
I figured it out now.
I figured it out.
If you didn't believe...
It's gonna turn it around.
How was I supposed to know?
It was my first time at Mr. Burr's house!
Oh my god, I like knocked her out of the car.
Alright, here we go.
This time I got it, guys.
I got it.
This has got to be a supportive wife and believe in my...
Just believe it.
Believe in my adventures and my antics.
I just...
Yeah, I understand it now, guys.
Wee!
It's...
I'm basically getting free money every time I break the window, too!
Free money!
It's my free money hack.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, we might have, like, bumped into several things.
But, like, it's okay.
Just a couple of hurdles.
Alright.
We go this way.
Guys, we will at least...
We will complete at least Marge's level.
Like, I missed the ramp.
I forgot all about the ramp.
I...
Let's get it.
Just keep on believing!
Keep on believing, guys!
I have enough speed!
Speed!
I told you.
I had enough speed.
I...
No, it's not over yet!
It's not over yet!
Guys, it's not over yet!
I can do this in 20 seconds!
There you go!
16!
Okay, where's the ramp?
Where's the ramp?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
9 seconds.
Right here.
Right now.
I'm gonna make it.
I...
Everyone better stay here!
Okay.
Look, I got a little too excited.
I got it.
Okay.
I got...
Now that I know.
Now that I know where to...
I know where to go now!
Guys, I know where to go now!
No, no, no you guys!
I know where to go!
It'll be fine.
It'll be fine!
Thank you for this super chat, thank you, Thank you!
Guys, it's all...
It's trial and error!
It's traveling there.
It's the car.
It's the car, I believe.
It's literally... it's the car, guys.
It's such a slow car.
Okay.
We gotta get that.
Alright, alright.
Guys, it's the car.
They have to... they have to increase the hitbox.
It's not my fault.
Alright.
No, no, no, Marge.
No, no, no.
It's the car, Marge.
Stop.
You gotta keep believing, Marge.
It's not you, it's the car.
Alright.
Woo!
Okay, and then I know there's a ramp, right?
Guys, just believe.
Just believe.
Woo!
I'm gonna make it!
Look at that!
I've consistently made it every time!
Okay, look.
And I have, like, at least 40 seconds now instead of 20.
Remember when I had, like, 20 seconds and I still made it?
Now I have even more.
Okay.
Alright, this is fine.
Alright.
I'm gonna time it.
I'm gonna make it!
Yeah!
Ah!
Oh, I'm trying to drive to clean up his house!
Where does he live?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I can make this.
Oh, no.
I can make it.
Get away from the black sedan.
I just gotta drive.
Oh, no.
Sorry about that.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, this is not fair.
This is not fair.
Somebody hit the black car!
Oh, I did it.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Drive to clean his house still.
Oh, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
It's fine.
I...
That's why...
This is why...
Guys, this is why I failed the mission several times.
So I could get more money.
It's okay.
That's why I purposely failed the mission several times.
So I could get the money to pay my bail.
I told you.
It's all coming together.
There.
Now.
You might and should ask some other old folks about it.
Maybe try around the graveyard.
Wait, what?
Thanks, Cletus.
Twerent nothing.
How about...
I have to go to the cemetery?
Trust the process, guys.
Always trust the process.
Always trust...
Everything I do, there's a plan.
Do the grand things of life.
There's always a plan.
Guys, don't worry.
I always have a plan.
I pretend to be bad at the game now.
So that when I do the harder levels, you guys are gonna be like, Whoa.
Guys, it's all...
I'm only at step two in my 25 step plan.
Guys, this is only step two.
Alright.
I'm sandbagging, so when we're at level five, you be like, Whoa.
Oh, Doki.
When did you learn to do that?
Alright, here we go.
We gotta go this way.
Guys, I wanna be a cop again.
Let me be a cop.
Wait, hello, Mo Man.
Hans Mo Man!
Wait, why do I have to talk to Mo Man?
What?
What curfew?
What...
What did you do?
I see the crop circle.
Talk to Abe.
He mentioned crop circles once.
Hurry up and get to the home before the police lock the doors.
Oh!
The retirement home curfew!
Wait, they locked the retirement?
Oh my god, that's pretty fucked.
They locked the retirement home.
Oh no.
You don't want the elderly to get...
I mean, no wonder they have to, guys.
The elderly, they commit crime if you don't lock them up.
You're not very good at this.
Yeah, I can't let the elderly roam around and commit crime, guys.
Okay.
Where I got this.
I'm a professional.
You're not very good at this.
Yeah, they get freaky in there.
Oh wait, I already did it.
Wait, come...
Where am I?
Waste the retirement home!
They have nothing to lose!
Exactly!
They have nothing else to lose!
Hello Abe.
If I kill him, I don't have to pay for his...
Stay at the retirement!
Abe, I need to talk to you.
Whoops!
Sorry!
It was all an accident.
I could take life insurance out of him.
Do you know anything about crop circles?
What?
Huh?
I can't tell you about crop circles right now.
Those lousy renegades stole my pills.
Without my ag relieve, I'll start fighting nurses.
You don't need the lawsuit!
You don't...
Darn...
Rickest...
Crap circles and...
Bang...
Agrilee...
Oh dear.
Oh no.
He's going through it.
He doesn't have his meds.
From the bullies before time runs out.
That's like a problem I heard.
That like...
Like...
Nurses would steal...
The...
Like nurses and volunteers.
Where is the bullies?
Oh!
I have to go to the playground.
I was like, where are they?
I think they steal the medication.
And then they like sell it or something.
Or take it for recreational.
Woo!
Yeah, I heard about that.
From a TV show.
Sorry!
I had...
I may or may not have heard about it from a TV show.
Which is like practically accurate if you think about it.
Alright.
Gotta go to the playground.
Gotta go to the school.
Don't worry, I'm coming over!
Give me back my...
My...
Father-in-law's meds!
It's better than getting news from Twitter, guys.
Yeah!
We traded it to some dudes in a black car for these play dudes.
Check it out, man.
This one's got an interview with the guy who invented the wah-wah pillow.
That's true though.
Playboy has actually really good interviews and stuff.
Like they actually have...
It's not just nudes.
It has articles.
They actually have like journalistic integrity.
Isn't that crazy?
Playboy has more journalistic integrity than other...
Journalism websites.
Okay, Father...
Okay, he's gonna have...
Drop random.
I don't know about now.
Ever since like Heath Ledger died.
Wait, not Heath Ledger.
That's the actor.
Oh...
Hugh Hefner!
Ever since...
I was like, wait, no.
Heath Ledger is the...
The Joker actor.
Ever since Hugh Hefner...
They...
They're...
They both start with age!
Ever since Hugh Hefner died.
I don't know if it's like still true though.
I don't keep...
They both start with age!
It's an honest mistake!
I'm trying to...
Guys, please!
I'm trying to get my...
My grandfather's meds!
Please!
It's all perfectly legal!
I'm trying to get my...
Oh no, where is it?
No!
I'm gonna get rested and fail this mission!
This is not fair.
Why are you doing on my side of the road?!
This is actually not fair.
This is not fair.
Where did he keep dropping meds?
Oh there it is.
There it is.
Here we go.
No!
What?!
And I have to go back!
Okay, guys, it's fine.
I didn't get arrested.
I didn't get arrested, guys.
I need to get this car out of my hands.
This car is too fucking wide.
Guys, I'm gonna fail this mission so I can leave.
So I can, like, grab an actual car.
Okay.
Uh... We'll grab... We'll have my daughter drive me.
Oh, that...
It's okay, guys.
I have to get another car.
I need my daughter to drive me.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
Alright, now it'll be fine.
Now it'll be fine.
Now I have a smaller car and also I'm faster.
This is all going according to plan.
And then we go this way and then that's... Oh my god.
Oh, that's funny that Lisa thinks she has college money.
There we go.
See?
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Alright, Nelson.
Look, I have your boyfriend right here, Lisa.
Alright.
Time to do this again.
Alright, and then I repaired the car and then...
Look, the reason why I failed that mission was because I was getting chased by cops.
Alright.
That's fine.
See?
Look at that.
The game is easier!
The game is easier now.
I told you.
When your...
When your 10 year old daughter drives you, it just gets surprising.
Oh no.
Please.
There's a garbage truck.
This is not fair.
He's body blocking the man!
He's literally body blocking!
How is that my fault?
Are you fucking...
What is the hitbox?
What...
Okay, this is not fair.
Sometimes the hitbox is like 80 meters tall, and sometimes it's like 0.1.
A bad anarchy.
RNG.
Alright, this is fine, this is fine.
I figured it out.
I blame my 10-year-old daughter.
She could have drove me better.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I'm okay now.
Mate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Margie's car known on this game to be unstable as fuck, making all the emissions incredible.
See, I told you, it's the car.
It's the car, guys.
It's the car.
It's not me.
I knew it.
I knew I wasn't coping.
I knew it was always the car.
It's never me.
It's just the car.
Reasonable.
Alright.
See, look at that.
It's fine now.
I figured it out.
See, it's fine now.
I figured it out for real.
Wait, a U-turn?
It does that?
Wait, that's illegal.
You're supposed to drive one way.
Wait, where is the car?
Where is the car?
Why is it driving like that?
Oh, my God.
I am like...
I'm not going slow.
I'm just... I'm just really worried.
I'm just scared.
Oh, no.
I'm trying to make sure I grab everything.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
As long as we pick up every item, it's okay.
Item dropped.
Okay.
Eight.
Nine.
Just one more.
Just drop one more, little guy.
Where is it?
Where's the last one?
Are you fucking... Are you fucking serious?
Why is it over there?
No.
Oh, my God.
What?
Okay.
That is not my fault.
Like, that's actually cheating.
Toki got... How did I get outplayed?
He's actually cheating!
He's... Oh, my God.
He dropped it at the edge of the... the fucking... the fucking, uh, like, ramp.
Police, did you get his number?
Are you serious?
I just went through so much.
I went through so much.
I don't understand.
Why are you like this?
I...
Okay, nice.
Where's the retirement home?
I don't know where I am anymore.
I am so lost.
Oh, there it is.
I figured it out.
Yippee!
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Crazy medicine, Grandpa.
Hot diggity!
Sweet, sweet medication!
Gimme, gimme, gimme!
What the fuck?
Oh, no.
He's asleep.
Just hit him.
I can't just hit him.
That's the easiest way to wake him up.
Wake up.
Wake up, Grandpa.
Grandpa, please.
We need to find your son.
More speed!
Wait, this... That's... It's next door!
I don't need to drive my car for this!
What's this?
Is that milk?
Is that milkies?
What did I get?
Guys, I didn't drive him over.
I gave him a little tap.
It's called a love tap.
You ever heard of that?
Look, I'll do it again.
Wake up.
Oh, shit.
See?
He's awake!
He talked!
Trucker's Choice Stay Alert Capsule?
Oh, my God.
I drugged my father-in-law.
What?
Ha, ha, ha!
I drove in a water car.
Okay, okay.
It was so long ago that I'll have to describe it in sepia tone.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot.
It was sort of a cosmic kind of thing.
Shaped kind of like a planet with an old-fashioned radio antenna coming off it.
A planet with an antenna?
What?
Oh, it's a UFO!
Oh, it's Buzz Koya!
I didn't think it was at the Quickie Mark.
That's it.
It was on a bottle of pop.
Maybe that will jog Bart's memory.
Oh!
I just got a sugar rush him!
Yippee!
Alright.
This has to be the hardest level so far.
I've... I realized...
I've been, like...
I've been, like, stuck on Marge's level for an...
for an abnormally long time.
Abnormal...
Abnormally.
Abnormally?
Ab-anomally?
Ab-
Abnormally.
Abnormally?
Abnormally long amount of time.
There we go.
I got it.
Guys, I...
Heart attack over.
Heart...
Heart attack's over, guys.
I'm okay now.
Oh, I have to go visit Bart.
Okay.
Oh yeah, this couch is actually... okay, so they retconned it.
Actually not retconned, but they didn't throw it back, but this couch was actually owned by Ned Flanders.
Yeah, it's the wrong room.
That's why I had to go to Bart's room earlier.
Oh my gosh, now everything makes sense.
Can I shortcut this?
I can, nice.
Alright.
Okay, parkour.
Nice, alright.
Alright.
Hello, Bart.
Wait, I want to change to my cop.
Cop uniform.
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna scare him straight.
You know, like this, that, you know, okay, back then when we like didn't care about giving children PTSD, we had shows where like, um, cops cut, like we bring criminals in and then like, like scare the shit out of the children and be like, if you do this,
this is what just gonna happen.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna fuck you up in jail.
What?
Do you know what I can use this design?
That's the alien mind control cola.
They gave us time to get up in the alien spaceship.
They're using it to make the town go crazy.
Oh, thank God.
We did it.
Out of your trance.
I was so worried.
Later, I'm going to the arcade.
Oh.
He's okay now.
Nice.
Oh, I did it!
I am Officer Marge!
We're gonna collect all the evil cola cans before time runs out.
I'll do my best.
Alright, time to collect...
Fart, please.
Fart, please!
Don't make mommy angry.
Alright, we gotta collect all the cans.
Wait, there's like... money though.
Wait, this is important.
Go where?
I might fail that mission, but this is important.
Bum bum.
Look, Fart.
We are somehow paid for your...
college education.
As if.
Fart.
Alright, I might have to like redo this mission, because I definitely did not come...
Wait, where is it?
How do I...
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, there's no way I'm completing this...
Fart.
I need a long island iced tea.
Not wrong.
No, not 30 of them.
Now it's parkour!
Press the button.
Bum bum.
Guys, you think I'm gonna make it?
That's like...
I missed that jump.
Guys, I'm definitely gonna make it, guys.
Yes!
Okay, now I believe myself less.
Now...
Okay, now I don't know.
Now I might not make it.
Look, we were going to make it, okay?
I just...
I made a...
I messed up.
I might have messed up.
I might...
Bum bum.
And then...
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god,
please.
How do I get there?
I don't understand!
It's Bart's fault.
Why...
Why did you have to...
Get abducted!
It's Bart's fault.
I'm victim blaming.
Can you pick it up a little bit?
Oh my god, I'm so close!
Even after all the times I messed up!
I can't believe it!
I actually...
I could've got it even after all the times I messed up!
I was one cat away!
I can't believe it.
It was actually one cat.
If I didn't get distracted by money!
It's all Bart's fault.
That's Seki, right?
I'm an adult!
I can blame children!
So close!
I...
The root of all evil.
It's Chow's fault, not me.
Oh my god.
I'm legally allowed to blame children.
I'm an adult.
Alright.
Ba-dum.
This is like actual brain rot music right now.
Please!
Where is your shadow?
How am I supposed to know?
Where is my cat?
I can't see the shadow!
Okay.
It's not my fault.
It's poor game design right here for this.
There's no shadow.
How was I supposed to know?
How was I supposed to know the depth perception if I don't have a shadow to tell me where it is?
Alright, this way.
And then...
Oh wait, there is a shadow.
Why is the shadow there, but not on the roof?
See the shadow here!
Nice, we did it.
Where's Apu?
Oh wait, the cooking mart is next door.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I just... I literally just shimmied across.
Alright, Apu.
What happened here?
Who's selling these Buzz Colas?
I swear that you're selling a tainted cola.
Where's this stuff coming from?
There is little here not tainted in some way.
Even the astrology scrolls give poor advice.
But, I will get to the bottom of this.
Yeah, isn't like his hot dogs made of like...
Made of roll kill?
And if I find the destroyer, I'm gonna give them a piece of my mind.
Careful, Mrs. Simpson.
This cola makes people do irrational things without guilt.
It is as though they have bottled the effects of a raging frat gegger.
That's right.
You don't want to piss off a Karen.
They've done it.
They pissed her off.
The scariest thing you can ever do.
Okay, we gotta call my...
We gotta call my daughter.
Drive me again.
Alright.
Alright, Lisa.
Oh shit.
Um...
Alright, maybe not.
Maybe...
Maybe not that car.
Uh...
Let's just drive the...
Let's get the Kremlin.
Alright, there we go.
Yeah, I might not.
Oh wait, I need a tougher car.
I'm supposed to ram things.
Okay.
You're right.
I forgot.
It's Mr. Plow tab.
Can you give me a lift?
There you go.
Alright, Officer Marge.
About to commit legal crime.
There we go.
Don't worry.
I got Mr. Plow.
Oh no.
I swear to God.
If I have to do...
If I...
Guys, if I fail this mission...
Do I have to do a certain mission again?
Guys.
Please don't tell me I have to do this again.
I have to collect cola again.
Oh no.
Not this one.
Okay, it's a new mission.
Thank God.
Okay.
Oh, I should've got the bus.
I should've got the bus.
I forgot how fuck these...
Oh!
Get over here!
I'm an angry housewife!
Finish.
Finish fast.
There's nothing more dangerous than pissing off a bored housewife.
I have nothing else in my life cause I quit my career for my husband.
No time for cars.
That's all I have.
That's fucking right.
I'm a trip.
There's nothing else I have in my life.
I used to have a successful career.
Not very good at this.
And now...
I'm trying to raise three kids!
On a paycheck that my husband...
That can barely support them!
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
I told you.
Never piss off a housewife.
She has nothing to lose!
She already quit her entire life for him!
Too real.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Alright, that was easy.
Thank God.
It's a miracle we still have a home!
I destroyed another one!
What do you mean?
My job's not over!
My job's not over?
There's no way.
Wait, what?
It just drove past me.
It can do that?
It just drove past me just like that.
What?
Oh, no.
Wait, how many do I have to destroy?
There's more than one?!
Okay, that should destroy the truck a little bit, you know?
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright, and then...
Oh, wait!
I got an idea!
I just push it back.
Push you back.
And then I do this.
And then I...
Okay, I'm like actually losing time doing that.
I...
Oh my God, I should've got the school bus.
I should've got the school bus.
Oh my God, why did I get the school bus, guys?
Oh, this is a lot harder.
This is a lot harder.
Being in a corridor is a lot harder, guys.
Wait.
Oh my God, I can't...
Oh my God, this is it.
This is the plan.
Put him in the corner!
He doesn't know what to do!
He's hitting himself!
This is it!
He doesn't know!
Alright.
A few more hits.
Oh my God, he's so confused.
He's actually hitting himself!
Why are you hitting yourself?
Oh no!
Yeah!
Okay, nice.
Alright, we did it.
Beat him up in the corner.
I need a wrench.
Somebody, please give me a wrench.
Alright, wait.
Power walking is good for my god, it's Jesus Christ.
Oh my God, thank God.
I can't...
I can't get another car.
Reload.
Alright, nice.
Next car.
I got...
Where am I?
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Sorry, I was in the sky for a little bit.
I got a little confused.
Oh no.
Oh no, this car is too wide.
This car is too wide!
No!
Where am I?
Nice girls, finish fast.
Okay.
It's okay, I figured it out.
He's gotta ram your car a little bit back and forth.
I got spirit.
I got spirit, guys.
Okay, am I not?
Oh my God, I see it.
I see it.
I see the last truck.
I...
I'm gonna destroy three?!
Oh, guys, I think...
Oh, thank God.
Guys, there is a chance that I have...
I'll have to do this again.
I don't believe...
You know, me getting this...
Me getting two was already, like, a miracle.
I...
No!
I should've got the bus!
Why did I get the bus?!
No!
Why?
I didn't realize!
Oh, no.
Guys, it's over.
I stopped believing.
There's no corners for me.
There's no corners for this!
No!
I got map environment!
Oh, no.
No!
Stupid garbage truck!
It's already over.
And then I'm gonna get arrested.
And then I'm gonna get arrested?!
Oh my God, the cops will help me!
The cops...
I should pay more attention.
You're supposed to help me!
I'm part of your team!
I thought he was gonna help me.
I thought we were in this to get there.
We're nearly part of the same team!
No!
Are you blind?
Where is he?
No!
Oh my God!
No, I'm hitting every car except...
I forgot to hit himself!
Hit himself, but it does it better!
No!
Everyone better stay on my way!
Alright.
I'm getting another car.
I'm getting another car that I can't get the bus.
Oh my God...
The damaging missions are the fucking worst!
They are actually the fucking worst missions in this game!
They will be the death of me.
What do you... What?
Okay, why put a fucking wrench in there?
It's like... Oh my god.
No, no Doki, calm down.
Calm down.
I don't know where to go.
Where is he?
Where even is the truck anymore?
Where did the truck go?
Where did... I'm gonna sit here while I... Guys, I'm gonna bet the mission fail and then I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'm not trying for this part.
Okay, I'm ready for real.
I'm so ready.
I'm so ready, guys.
This time I'm built.
I got the bus.
There's nothing they can do now.
I don't know where the car is, but there's nothing they can do now.
I'm so ready.
Auto.
We got this, Auto.
Alright.
I'm so sad.
I put that guy in the corner and I fucked it up.
That's right.
I am nothing to lose.
Oh, wait, wait, wait a minute.
You're not supposed to do that.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
You just... casually drove away?
Oh my god.
Geez.
Why can't I have a bigger car?
Oh, nice.
Guys, you like that?
That's called driving.
That's right.
Alright, nice.
I... oh my god.
Guys, please, there has to be an easier way.
What's the actual strat?
What's... what's the... how do they do this?
How do they speedrun this part?
I don't understand.
How do they... how do they speedrun this is absolute hell.
Just ram harder.
I don't understand.
I'm ramming as much as I can.
Just hit it.
Just hit it really, really hard.
But like... I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Here you go.
Just...
Boom.
Alright, nice.
Cool.
Oh my god, what?
Try hard.
I don't understand.
I'm hitting everything but this stupid fucking truck.
Please!
Just hit yourself.
You're one hit.
Smash into a tree.
I'll do my best.
I don't understand.
No!
And I've missed.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Alright, here we go.
This time.
I'll do my best.
There we go.
I'm not very good at this.
Alright.
Here you go.
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't play!
It's just a tiny corner!
How do you...
How do you speedrun this?
This is absolute hell.
I don't have any pockets.
Okay.
Are you even watching?
Oh!
Okay, guys.
I used a dunder card to ram into him.
Yeah, who put that wall there?
It was out there when I was...
When I drove 10 years ago.
Oh my god.
And then the cops gonna come?!
Here we go.
I don't understand.
You guided it to walls?
I was up to...
Where?
Where's the wall?!
I'm on the open road!
There we go.
And I hit myself.
And then he drove around me.
Oh my god.
Please.
I don't understand.
Why are you like this?
Oh my god!
I'm trying to...
How would I get arrested for doing my job?!
I shouldn't get arrested when I'm doing my own job.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I...
I almost missed too.
That was the worst...
That's the worst part.
The fact that I almost missed that jump.
Oh my god.
I got...
Okay, guys.
I gotta wait until the cops don't get me.
I can't...
I gotta wait here.
I gotta wait...
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I gotta chill.
I gotta wait until it's ready.
I gotta wait...
I gotta wait before I commit more crime.
Alright, here we go.
Now we're fine.
Alright, nevermind.
I hit a car.
But now we should be fine.
Now we can commit more crime, right?
Now we're legally allowed...
To commit more crime.
Okay.
Here we go.
That's right.
I'm coming for you.
How did you take zero damage?!
I'm right here!
Oh my god.
The little damage that I took.
Oh, that's gonna cost me.
I am so torn.
Alright.
In the corner.
In the corner!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Please.
You gotta go in the corner, sir.
How the fuck did I...
Oh shit.
Please, please.
Hit somebody.
Please.
That's all I want.
Please hit something.
Anything.
Yes!
Nice!
No!
I started automatically?!
Oh my god.
Why did it start?
Why did it start automatically?
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
I just got here!
Nice!
Yes!
That was a big one!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Guys, I might be getting better.
Guys.
Is this possible?
Guys!
Could it be?
I'm getting better at driving?
I'm doing it!
Leave the driving to me, dude.
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm figuring it out.
I'm slowly figuring it out, guys.
Oh, fuck!
Fuck your car!
No!
Oh, no.
Where is it?
Where's the car?
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
That's fine!
Keep going against the walls!
Yes!
Drive into the train!
Hit yourself!
Oh, no!
No, no!
I'm losing track of it!
No!
Please!
Please hit yourself!
No!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Oh, no!
Don't you do not give me the cops after everything I've been through!
Slow and steady.
We follow traffic laws.
We are law-abiding citizens.
Look at us go!
Oh!
And then- Oh!
There's a stop sign!
Look- Look both ways!
Alright!
Left turn!
Now we're law-abiding citizens.
Oh!
There's another stop sign!
What do you mean get away from Wiggle!
What do you mean?
Get away from Wiggle!
Everything- After everything I've been through, I'm being chased by the cops!
Are you fucking- This car is so bad for chasing!
This is- This is a drive- This is a rav car!
I can't believe it!
This is not fair!
Oh my god!
No!
And then the- And then the actual cops are here!
Oh, that's a break down- Don't!
Don't!
This car was not been in...
It's not fair!
Don't-
Oh!
No!
I did...
I just...